all right October yes October where are
you from originally where'd you grow up
I'm from Chattanooga Tennessee
tell me about your family growing up
um I was born and raised with my parents
so I
just me and my parents
um they weren't really like huge family
people so
um I have a half sister but I didn't
grow up with her she was raised she was
my dad's daughter but I didn't grow up
with her she was raised in Kentucky you
were kind of an only child yeah raise
his only child
how would you describe your childhood
um my childhood was really really good
my so more context on my parents so my
mom she was a model
um body piercer an artist and my dad he
was into music he played guitar my dad
was a tattoo artist
um my dad was also just an artist in
general so growing up was really really
fun because my dad played guitar he was
constantly
um like like I don't know if touring is
the right word but playing all the time
so I was constantly just going to band
practice with my dad and watching him
play and going to tattoo conventions my
parents opened their own tattoo shop
when I was a year old so they worked
really really hard on that they had a
great tattoo shop I watched my mom model
when I was growing up so I mean it was
like that kind of like rock and roll
parents you know we were
always traveling we always went to
Mexico and California even though we
lived in Tennessee so that's like pretty
far
um so yeah it was great like I would
even like miss school so we could like
go on vacations and things like that so
I guess because of that it kind of put a
little bit of distance between me and
like the rest of my family
um my parents were just they were
younger when they had me so they were
just so busy doing stuff working and
partying and doing all the stuff that
the rest of my family didn't really you
know stay involved too much like of
course they still loved us and
everything but they they knew my parents
were so busy that they weren't like
constantly in the loop so they kind of
just assumed that I was great and I was
doing my thing and I would say with my
grandparents on the weekends
um like on both sides of my family but I
was with my parents a majority of the
time and also I had a babysitter because
my parents were so busy with the tattoo
shop so on the weekdays I would stay
with the babysitter and then on the
weekends I would usually stay with my
grandparents as long as like and like if
my parents were out of town if they were
in town a lot of the times my parents
brought me along so like the the
conventions the modeling all that
sounds like a fun childhood it was
really really fun yeah my childhood was
great
and your parents
got into drugs or were into drugs early
or later in their lives so
like my parents partied a lot
and I didn't really think anything of it
uh they would throw parties at the house
a lot and if they threw like really big
parties and I would stay with my
grandparents on the weekends um but a
lot of times they would just throw
parties while I was there and I would my
mom would just be wasted like both my
parents would be wasted
um but then I noticed that like
like I would have friends over on the
weekdays and then my mom would get super
drunk and then like my dad would like
get mad about it or my dad would also be
super drunk so I noticed that but it
never really like worried me at all I
was kind of like oh like my parents are
just party people it is what it is
um and then eventually my dad like
stopped drinking and that's when I kind
of got worried because my dad stopped
drinking to try and get my mom to stop
drinking and so I realized like okay
yeah my mom definitely does have a
problem because my dad is like maybe if
I stop drinking she'll stop too and it
didn't stop so
that's when I kind of saw like the
emotional side of my dad
um my mom was very like the control
freak I'm in charge I've got this and my
dad was more of the like hold my hand
through it I'm not sure if I'm okay kind
of guy so when my mom was just over here
like
struggling and I didn't know my dad was
like okay I'm gonna struggle too if
you're not okay so then my dad you know
he tried to stop drinking and my mom
kept on and that's when I saw my dad
like really struggle with his mental
health
um I saw my dad cry a lot and I I talked
to other people and they're like I've
never heard my dad cry and I'm like
really
um my dad was super emotional and he
would even try and get me to like say
things for him in case like it would
mean more to my mom so like he'd be like
you need to tell her that she needs to
stop drinking or
or something along that line you know
and would use me and it honestly kind of
made me look at my mom in a bad way I
was just like oh my gosh like my mom is
just this alcoholic and she doesn't care
about anything but
I didn't see what she was putting up
with especially because of my dad being
like that like my dad was always had
like anxiety and panic attacks and I
didn't like understand what it was he
would literally like pull over on the
side of the road and just like sit there
and be like no I can't drive like I'm
having a full-on panic attack and I
would just sit there and just wait until
he was done I had no idea that he was
like struggling with anything
so
um my mom just drinking drinking
drinking and my dad like my dad would
drink every now and then but he pretty
much like got the partying and stuff
like to a wraps
um right as I was like finishing
elementary school so I would say like my
elementary school like time period was
like great and it was super super fun
and then when I went into Middle School
is when I started to really see issues
so
I started to see domestic violence in
the home and I had never seen my parents
do anything like that that I would hear
them plead with each other like not to
hurt one another
um they would just scream at each other
for hours again my dad would pull me in
and be like look at your mom you need to
tell her blah blah and I would just be
like what you know
and it's sad because I don't think my
dad realized like how harmful that was I
think he just felt super alone and was
like why is no one else like getting
this through your head to my mom and I
was just there
so in Middle School
like the vacation stopped and that's
when I knew like things were going bad
was because my mom couldn't even like
keep up with all the stuff we had been
doing my whole life so no more trips to
Mexico
um she ended up buying a home here in
California
um I can't remember exactly when I think
it was a little bit into me being in
middle school and so we would stay in
that home out here during the summer and
we would stay out here for the whole
summer and it was always horrible
because my mom would just be wasted the
whole time and me and my dad were just
stuck here dealing with it and
I think like during the three years I
was in Middle School I started to see my
mom's appearance change a lot like her
stomach started protruding a lot and my
mom was like a model really skinny uh
really tall and always so healthy like
my mom was a health freak so when I saw
her like having a belly
I was really confused because like
it wasn't like a fat belly if that makes
any sense like it was literally like a
forward like protrusion
um like inflammation exactly
inflammation and my dad would just be
like why do you look like that like
you're fat you're why do you look like
this and again like he wasn't even
trying to hurt her but he was like why
the hell do you look like this all of a
sudden and uh her jaw like all the skin
started to droop a little bit and she
just told me and my dad that it was a
thyroid problem and she genuinely she
genuinely believed that it was a thyroid
problem and she was taking medicine for
it and I mean that could have
contributed to it but that was not the
reason that she was looking like that
so
things yeah like I said things were
really really bad when I was like going
through Middle School all the fun stuff
was stopping my parents were fighting
all the time I started to see the
domestic violence and things like that
and at this point my family like really
didn't talk to me like
um some of my grandparents on my like my
mom's parents uh her dad had passed and
her mom was getting older
so I would like occasionally stay with
my grandparents on my dad's side but it
was like
it was super rare I almost never saw my
grandma on my dad's side that much
um
so
um when I started High School it was
like the summer before I started my
freshman year we were out here in
California and my dad was out here guest
spotting in a tattoo shop
and my dad had kind of always dealt with
like back pain from tattooing since
you're just like hunched over like that
and so he asked someone if they had like
a painkiller and so someone did and they
I I still to this day don't know like
what it was but they gave him a
prescribed painkiller and they gave him
a couple so he had taken some that day
and I think he had like taken some for
the next day and they like really really
helped him and he wasn't abusing them or
anything like that so he he found them
out here he was introduced to the
opioids out in California so then maybe
like August of my freshman year we went
back to Tennessee and
um that's when like things just started
getting so weird the first time I
actually noticed it was super duper
weird my parents used to have to drive
me to my bus stop so my dad drove me to
my bus stop and I showed him this song
um how could you leave us by NF in the
the song is literally about how this guy
lost his mom to pill addiction and I
just like it was so raw and emotional
and I'm like man like imagine going
through that and I don't know like I
swear I like put it down to the universe
because that was like one of the first
times I'd ever seen my dad hi
and I told him about it and of course
he's like I've never heard that blah
blah kind of brushing it off and then
that week like
his mannerism just got so exaggerated so
my dad was always like a funny guy like
a light-hearted guy a comedian type but
it was just like
really like inappropriate jokes and just
things that weren't funny or he like I
said just everything was super
exaggerated and I'm like why why is this
happening I could tell something was off
um
so then things started getting like
really really bad uh again I don't know
what my dad was taking exactly but it
eventually turned into Fentanyl and I
don't know like how soon it turned into
fentanyl but I would say pretty soon
because my dad started acting absolutely
insane and for anyone who's never seen
someone on fentanyl like I can't even
describe it it's just like constant
screaming yet like screaming like
screaming like there's someone out to
murder them yelling
um super strength like I feel like no
one mentions these things a weird
obsession with water
um slapping himself my dad would rip his
hair out my dad had dreadlocks so
yelling slapping kicking uh
he obsession with water like I said he
would like start exercising profusely
and like it like I know this sounds so
light-hearted but it was like horrible
like my dad would like do a bunch of
push-ups and then try and do like
pull-ups and like yank the whole door
frame off the wall
so one of the first like really big
instances I saw with my dad
um I used to ride horses I did it
competitively for like 11 years and I
was always at the barn so one day I was
at the barn and my mom picked me up
and me and my mom were not prepared for
what we walked into
um
so
we opened the door and I go to my room
and my whole room is flooded and there's
like water rushing out of the ceiling
and my dad's like somewhere in a room
screaming yelling crying who knows we
could just hear him uh my dad had
somehow punched kicked fell into I don't
know busted a water pipe that was
upstairs so it went through the ceiling
and completely flooded my room and I
couldn't sleep in there for the night
like it wasn't like destroyed but it
like there was standing water all over
the floor my bed was soaked everything
was soaked
and
I was like what the hell so my mom ended
up kicking my dad out that night and
sometimes she would like
um
this wasn't this was in April of my
freshman year so between like August to
April we hadn't really seen my dad do
anything like no serious event had
occurred until now we had just seen his
weird Behavior so
my mom kicked him out that night and we
almost never kicked my dad out but that
was just ridiculous so my mom kicked him
out for the night and I ended up
sleeping in our guest bedroom so then
I wake up for school and I hear my dad
yelling with my mom so obviously my dad
had come back sometime in the middle of
the night
and all of a sudden I hear my dad say
hit me again and I just hear this giant
crash both of them are screaming I just
run out of the room and I'm like can can
you guys stop like this is just insane
and then they just keep on and keep on
they're fighting and fighting and so
they're in the living room and it's like
a straight shot to the kitchen hallway
kitchen and my dad's like screw it I'm
out of here so he goes to leave and he
takes a gun that's like near the door
because we had weapons in the house
and he tries to leave and my mom just
takes off after him and I'm like
watching it because I was like in the
living room with them fighting so my dad
walks off tries to leave my mom jumps in
front of the door slams it and they're
sitting there fighting with a gun in
between their hands so I'm likes and
they're like here's the day I have to
watch my parents shoot each other
and I just fall to the ground and I just
I'm screaming like stop and I finally
screamed loud enough to where they heard
me and they looked over and they just
dropped the gun and they were pretty
much like what the hell are we doing
right now
and I was like someone calls the cops
right now like I cannot deal with this
so I ended up calling my sister and
what's crazy is my sister had grown up
in Kentucky and she was in Tennessee
going to college
and I've never talked to my sister
really like we were only as close as we
could be so I called her and I didn't
even tell her what happened I'm like
you've got to pick me up and take me to
school right now
and so she kind of knew that things were
bad with my parents but she had no idea
like what the reality of it was so she
shows up my dad calls the cops
thankfully so the cops roll up and then
my sister like came like right behind
them so it all happened pretty fast and
I was out of there
and um I got in the car and there was
like blood all over my arms from like I
try to break them up fighting before
they grabbed the gun and stuff like that
and I just like just seeing like my
parents blood on my arm as I'm like
being driven to
to high school
I was just like what like what is going
on and my sister like for sure thought
someone had died like thought one of
them had murdered each other but luckily
they didn't
I got to school I really wasn't able to
explain to her much what happened
I got to school and my friends started
laughing at me because my eyes were all
red they thought that I had just been
smoking a bunch of weed and I like
looked at them and I'm like you have no
idea what I just saw and what I just had
to intervene with and they they
immediately were just like oh [__]
and
it was just sad that my own friends were
like laughing at me after I had gone
through something so intense because I
had no idea
so my sister was nice enough to let me
stay with her that night
um even though I had never stayed to my
sister before like we're not close I
stayed with my sister and then
um she took me to school the next day
and I was just like not wanting to go
home at all so I decided that I was
gonna go at least like hang out after
school with my boyfriend at the time
so me and him we walk out to the student
parking lot and we weren't old enough to
drive but his brother was so we're out
in the student parking lot and my mom
calls me and I immediately knew
something was wrong
she told me that my dad overdosed behind
the wheel crashed the truck into a
telephone pole and it's totaled and he's
okay and he's in a hospital
the reason this truck is a big deal is
because my by this time my mom's dad had
passed he gifted this truck to my mom to
give to me when I was old enough to
drive it I was 15 at the time
he totaled my dead Grandpa's truck that
was a gift to me a year before I was
able to drive it
so of course I was super concerned about
my dad of course but like hearing my mom
on the phone and just how like destroyed
she was hurt so bad and I thought for
sure like this was going to be the
wake-up call for my dad and it was
literally just the first incident the
first big thing that happened
um
my mom really started to spiral after
this and she was drinking non-stop she
will she would constantly like hide
bottles around the house my mom drank
wine and that's another big thing people
think alcoholics can't die from beer of
wine that's such a lie you can die off
of anything that has alcohol in it if
you abuse it and
um I'm not laughing because it's funny
I'm laughing because it's ridiculous
that people think that you can die from
drinking wine it's true
so my mom would hide wine bottles all
over the house and then just be like I
don't know what you're talking about
blah blah and I would literally just
whip out a whole bag full and be like
you can stop lying because I already
found everything
um and
my mom just
it was weird because although like I
said like her stomach was getting bigger
and her her like skin was getting more
saggy she was losing so much body fat
and
it was just it was getting so bad
um
after my dad wrecked the truck my mom
bought him
a nice really nice BMW
and
um
my dad ended up getting sober for around
like a year or something like that it
was like it was like seven to eight
months maybe so maybe like my my 10th
grade year was pretty like mellow like
my dad actually like kinda got a wake-up
call from the truck situation I think he
was in and out of rehab like a couple
different times
um but
he yeah only stayed sober for a little
bit of time so
forward to my junior year of high school
that's when things started to get like
really bad again
um my dad
was constantly wrecking the car like he
he would just like nod out and just like
hit something
um
sorry I need to like gain my thoughts
for a second
um I'll go back to the tattoo shop so
if if my dad was acting like super duper
crazy and we needed him out of the house
we would like sometimes drop him off at
a hotel or we would ask him to go to the
tattoo shop and sometimes he would just
drive his BMW there or we would drop him
off we we tried really hard not to let
him drive just because obviously he
didn't need to be driving under the
influence
so
um we would drop him off at hotels and
he would just walk around the city at
night getting food and all kinds of [__]
so he would like walk back home and show
up with like four bags full of food and
just like nothing ever bothered him we
we dropped him off or maybe he drove
there to the tattoo shop one time and he
was just destroyed the tattoo shop he
just knocked stuff down he I don't
exactly know what happened but he
apparently knocked a skateboard Off the
Wall fell on his face and broke his nose
so he just showed up at our house two
black eyes and his nose gushing blood I
mean come on this is my dad
um he would walk in front of the street
naked he would have no clothes on in
front of me and scream at me that he is
fully clothed
um like it was horrible like this is my
dad you know like acting like a
full-grown toddler just because he was
completely out of his mind
and it was getting so hard for my mom
like the tattoo shop would be like her
safe place and you know my parents had
that tattoo shop for 18 years it was
only business they ever built and they
completely built it from the ground up
so my mom would just like hide at the
tattoo shop pretty much and my dad would
just show up all messed up and I would
either have to pick him up
um or my mom would take him home where
he would drive home
um that was one of the hardest things to
deal with towards the end of it was
because my dad was just running off
clients and uh my friends my friends
from high school would go there and be
like your mom gave me a piercing and she
smelled like alcohol the whole time and
so I left and so just like hearing stuff
like that uh it was just so hard people
would leave horrible reviews like my
friends about my parents just because
you know well not just because but you
know because of their addiction it was
sad because I'm like this is not them
this is just something that's coming out
of their issues
um
so my mom
like they were starting to get bad
reviews about my mom and my dad was just
constantly running off clients he
couldn't work
and so
um my dad
uh saw me jumping back and forth so much
but yeah my dad would just randomly like
drive the car around and he wrecked the
car
um on like two occasions before he ended
up totaling it
and and my mom was just pissed because
she bought him this car and
um he was just wrecking it left and
right and just being like I don't know
how that got there blah blah
and at this time like none of my family
was helping like I I talked to our
family members and
sometimes I would send them over to the
house to like check on my dad and they
would just sit there and like steal
stuff from my dad and I know this
because like I would be there sometimes
so I would like ask like my dad's
friends be like hey I'm really worried
about my dad
um can you just come over and and just
sit with him and they would just sit
there and like coax my dad into giving
like my Dad giving them things because
my dad like played guitar and stuff like
that so my dad built pedals so my dad
had like tons of nice pedals and tons of
nice things and he would just be like
yeah man here here because he was high
and it just made me sad because I would
call people over because I'm thinking my
dad is gonna either hurt someone or hurt
himself and they're coming over to steal
stuff from him
so that was one of the really big issues
was my dad's like emotional state was
really like coming to a head and
there were so many nights my mom just
she couldn't cover it up anymore and she
was sick of it you know we couldn't
sleep because my dad like I don't know
how to describe the screaming my dad
would scream for days straight he would
go outside and scream and people would
call the cops he would run in my room
and scream at my face he screamed so
much there was no sleep if we tried to
sleep like I also I was downstairs and
my parents never really like slept in
the same bed towards the end of it so my
mom would just sit upstairs with the
door closed and I'm sharing a wall with
my dad who's banging on the wall
screaming saying he's gonna end his life
so there was so many nights well I
literally no sleep had school in the
morning
um where I would just hold my dad in my
arms on the ground while he cried and
he's like I'm worthless I'm the F up I'm
gonna hurt myself blah blah blah and I
would just have to sit there and and
just like baby him out of it in a way
and it got to the point where my dad
would use like him going to harm himself
it's kind of like a scare tactic so if
me and my mom were like just fed up with
him he would be like no one loves me and
I'm gonna go like hurt myself and you
guys are gonna be responsible and he
would literally do that or say that
and it was so hard because it got to a
point where I'm like am I a bad person
for ignoring him
or like because I had no idea if he was
being serious or not and I know like he
was obviously very emotionally
distraught but I mean he would do that
if he didn't get his way if we didn't
drive him to Dunkin Donuts
so he my dad was just so emotional and
my mom was just fed up with it she had
enough
um my dad couldn't work so my mom was
the only one working and she is drinking
herself to death so my mom got to the
point where she was like throwing up
every single day all the time like my
mom would wake up and just start
throwing up and
I just like of course I noticed it but I
was like
almost like mad at her in a sense
because I was just like Dad is doing so
bad and now you're getting so much worse
like
it was so hard to deal with because I
actually my junior year
um well after my sophomore year I ended
up leaving public high school to go to
college so I actually graduated at 17
with a degree in science
um a two-year degree in science and my
high school diploma so I like
my last two years of high school were
brutal I did summer school over my
junior year I was like grinding my ass
off because I was like this is the one
thing I'm not gonna let my parents take
away I'm gonna get my education and I'm
gonna get out of here
and so the fact that I went through
college at 16 years old
like and and did so well you know I I
can't even believe I did that because I
I went like several days without sleep
me and my mom would sometimes go to a
hotel
um but that was worth nothing because we
would just be checking the security
cameras all night long calling my dad
making sure he was there and not driving
um making sure no one was like pulling
up at the house anything like that so if
I tried to leave and get some sleep it
was pretty much useless because I was
just so worried about my dad I remember
one time I was in the shower and I
didn't hear my dad screaming for like a
couple seconds and I immediately freaked
out because I thought he had harmed
himself so I just flew out of the shower
and I was like Dad like I started
screaming and he was just standing in
the hallway like looking all confused
like why the hell are you running out
here and I just like totally broke down
because I was like I can't even take a
shower without being worried that my
dad's gonna hurt himself if I don't have
my eyes on him or my ears on him
and that's when I knew like I can't do
this I I cannot sit here and be
responsible for them
and um I love them through everything
and I think that's so important I loved
them the whole time and I supported them
the whole time even though my friends
were texting me saying hey your dad just
bought drugs in a Walmart parking lot
you know my my parents or my friends
were literally texting me being like hey
I just saw your mom at the liquor store
hey I just saw your dad running across
the road like
it was so hard for me to deal with
because I was working so hard on trying
to get my life right and just knowing
that my parents were just destroying
themselves was horrible
so
um
my last year of high school
um I can't remember like the exact
timelines or anything like that but my
dad
um
he ended up totaling the BMW
and but before that before that he got
pulled over outside of the tattoo shop
my dad got pulled over like a couple
different times I think and my dad got
pulled over one time with his dog so I
had a dog my mom had a dog and my dad
had a dog and we tried everything we
could to not let my dad take the dog but
he would put up a huge fight it was
basically impossible so my dad got
pulled over with the dog one time and
luckily one of the workers at the shop
like saw when they were going home they
saw my dad being pulled over and they
ended up getting the dog
and uh like
it was just crazy I think my dad ended
up getting arrested and got a DUI and
got in trouble for possession
and um
and then
like even one time we called that same
worker to come get the dog from my dad
my dad took off running after her car to
try and get the dog back so like it was
just like ridiculous we couldn't even
keep the dog safe and that we'd only had
this dog for like two years like we'd
had the other dogs for a while but my
dad's dog was like pretty newly adopted
so then
my dad ends up running off the side of
the road one day
and the dogs in the car
and my dad ends up getting like two DUIs
and the cars totaled and he goes to jail
and the dog stays the night in jail with
my dad
and like I know that sounds like comical
but that's ridiculous I cannot believe
like that the police let him do that
because they just like my dad was so
baby like my dad was telling me yeah
they they were talking to me and they
were giving me food and they were
hanging out with me and the dog like
nothing was putting my dad in his place
every time he got punished it was like a
little vacation we dropped him off at a
hotel he would just run around and go
get food and drugs he goes to jail and
he's hanging out with the cops with his
dog like I literally could not believe
that I'm over here crying because I find
out my dad's been arrested it might like
I had a great childhood my parents had
never done anything like this so to hear
my dad is going to jail is like insane
so my dad like this was the second time
he went to jail he totaled the car
and my mom was just done like my mom was
completely done with him and by this
point my mom was getting like really
really sick
um
and
yeah I can't I'm struggling to like
think of the exact dates and everything
like that
so anyways
2021 was the year I was graduating
so I don't remember if my dad like
totaled the car before or after I
graduated I feel like it was before
so anyways my dad is still doing like
really really bad
um
and my mom's doing really bad and then I
had my graduation coming up
and I never planned for my graduation it
was crazy I I didn't think I was going
to survive living with my parents and I
was surprised that my parents even made
it to my graduation like I was really
shocked
um
so I graduated and everything like I
said got a two-year degree at 17 along
in my diploma and a couple days later my
dad didn't even remember that I
graduated he like I don't remember if we
were actually talking or if we were
texting and he was just saying something
like oh yeah like your graduation's
coming up and I was like
you went to my graduation it already
passed and that just like
oh man it just like sucked I was like
this drug has just ruined you and uh at
the time when my dad
um when my dad totaled the car he was
actually taking fentanyl cut with benzos
which is like the worst of the worst
right now I guess it's called tranq or
whatever
um
so my mom had bought the summer home
like I mentioned went way back when and
it had just been sitting out here in
California and I desperately wanted to
get the hell out of the house so I was
like Mom I'm gonna go to college in
California and I'm gonna live out there
so I actually was going to UC San Diego
great school I was shocked that I got in
um and honestly I did not want to go I
wanted to get the hell out of my parents
house I had already gotten my degree I
felt happy and by the time I got out
here I was burnt out like I had no
energy having to just be in survival
mode my whole life
and
um
so I moved out here and my parents were
really really helpful I could not have
done any of this without my parents my
parents my parents were great they were
great parents they just really had deep
personal issues
and um
it just caught up to them so I was out
here and I remember like my best friend
actually helped me move out too so my
mom my dad and my best friend were all
out here helping me and my dad and my
best friend flew back home to Tennessee
together and so it was just me and my
mom and I remember like my mom
was so drunk one night she was sitting
on the couch and I like could not help
it but I like was so angry and mad that
I like just got right up on her and was
like had my hand like on the back of the
couch over her and I'm like I have had
enough of this like it makes me want to
like harm you because I'm so angry that
like you cannot stop drinking and it was
scary because like my anger like really
it was bad at one point in Tennessee I
remember I pushed my dad and
I like really got my [__] together after
that because I was like this is so scary
that I have no control over my anger to
the point where I can harm someone and I
never let that happen again I'd never
ever ever meant to hurt my dad and I I
didn't hurt him he literally just fell
over but I knew then that this was
bigger than me that their problems were
taking over me
so then like my mom goes back to
Tennessee and I'm out here on my own
and my mom is calling me in the middle
of the night you need to please help me
can I please move in your dad won't stop
blah blah blah the shop is a mess we've
lost all the customers and then I have
my dad blowing me up being like your mom
is an effing liar look at all this stuff
like sending me photos of bottles and
stuff like that so it was really hard
because I had my dad going your mom's
destroying me and my mom going your
dad's destroying me and I'm like you
guys need to get a divorce and that was
one of the biggest things that I
couldn't shake them my dad was like you
just want to break up the family and I'm
like I just want to see you better
because y'all both have issues and
you're just pointing the finger at each
other and you know like I said my dad
had been in and out of rehab and my mom
was like going to like a GI specialist
I'm like
this is not going to help you know what
I mean just totally taking the wrong
approach to things and I was like you
guys need to be separated if they would
have separated
I don't know if they would still be here
but I think things would have been a
little bit different
um
so I couldn't even keep my piece out
here because my parents were just
constantly just being like help me help
me and I'm out here just trying to get
my life together I ended up dropping out
two days into school because I was so I
was just burnt out I had no energy no
drive and honestly I had a really bad
feeling about my parents
um especially because my mom was like oh
yeah like
I'm gonna pay for your school blah blah
blah and I was like no you're not like
you made your own money through a tattoo
shop that you guys built and I just I
knew the reality of it like you're not
gonna be able to pay for this UC school
and I wasn't getting any scholarships or
anything like that so I just I dropped
out and I didn't feel guilty about it at
all because I just really needed to live
my life for a little bit and not my
parents life and I thought I was going
to be able to do that
so then Thanksgiving of 2021 oh not
Thanksgiving
um the beginning of December 2021 I went
to see my parents in Tennessee because
they didn't come out to see me for
Thanksgiving and I didn't go to see them
so I decided I would go like in between
Christmas and Thanksgiving to Tennessee
to kind of make it up with my family
and everything seemed like normal for
what it was
um and then I went back and then about a
week later my parents didn't come with
me but they end up flying separately
like a week later and my mom was a
completely different person like she
could barely walk she wouldn't like look
at me in the face she could barely talk
um she started bleeding out of her
rectum like there was just blood coming
out of her she was vomiting blood and my
mom had just turned 40. my mom's 40th
birthday was December 7th
so like I couldn't believe this because
like I've seen I've seen
two people die in front of me and I've
seen at least seven dead people and to
see like my mom like this like I
immediately knew that this was
irreversible
and
it was horrible because she had spent so
much time planning out this awesome
Christmas for me and she had asked so
many people about like what to get me
and things like that and
she gave me the best Christmas I'd ever
had that last Christmas and it was just
it meant so much to me because I knew
she wanted to make me happy because she
knew how much I was doing horrible
living with them
and or you know before I moved and I
guess that was kind of like her way of
making it up to me and also it made her
happy
so she ended up getting me like these
awesome pair of roller skates and just
she just planned it so much
and then I wanted to buy her a pair of
jeans because she would wear her jeans
until you could literally see her
underwear and I'm like girl you need to
get a new pair of jeans so I took her to
the Levi's Outlet near our house or near
where where we are out here
and she could barely get out of the car
like she was like walking
like this
and she apologized to me and she's like
I'm really sorry I'm walking so slow and
I was just like
why the hell is this happening like what
is this like I wasn't mad at her but I
was like this is so like far like this
is so irreversible
and so we go into the store she goes
like this and goes I don't think I'm
gonna find anything and so we get in the
car and I just cry and I'm like Mom you
have got to go get help like I don't
know if help is gonna help you but
you've got to go do something go to a
hospital anything and my dad was pretty
much at the same point as me just like
throwing his hands up in the air being
like I don't know what to do because my
mom was super hard-headed you know
blamed everything on her thyroid blamed
everything on genetic stomach problems
when we all knew what the hell was going
on and what's crazy was my mom didn't
even drink when she was out there
um when she was here in California
visiting me and I was like why the hell
are you so wasted blah blah blah my dad
was like she hasn't even drank it was
just the lack of oxygen to her brain and
her organs shutting down I mean she was
like
just so confused like me and my dad
would be talking and she would just look
at us like this and stare and we were
like what like
and I just remember like
me and my dad just pleading and pleading
with her to go to a hospital she goes to
a clinic to get a coven test
and I'm of course it's negative because
she doesn't have freaking covid and I'm
just like
I'm done like I'm like please go home
right now and go like to a hospital
because she didn't have health insurance
out here so that's why she was like I
can't see a doctor blah blah blah as if
we cared we would have paid for it
but anyways she wanted to wait until she
got home
and then she didn't see a doctor for
like three or four days until she got
back home so it's the new year it's 2022
January
and
she finally goes to a hospital but this
is when like covet had resurged so they
were like not letting anyone in to go
see her and it was like really bad so my
mom ended up getting cleared for a liver
transplant but she would have had to be
she would have had to go to Memphis
which is like two hours away she would
not be airlifted well by the time they
had a freaking bed open for her she had
too much stuff on her to transport
she had cirrhosis of the liver yeah so
um they called me like the doctor like
called me on the three-way call oh let
me mention this
like I said covet's going on my dad is
the only one that can see her so can you
imagine me trying to figure out what the
hell's going on with my mom is my dad's
high on fentanyl going to see her and it
also breaks my heart that that's what my
mom had to deal with like that's the
last thing my mom can remember is my dad
being high in the room with her it just
like makes me sick and not at my dad but
just the fact that she could not get
away from him and my mom loved my dad
but she did not love the fentanyl
addiction that my dad was severely
robbed of she couldn't get away from it
and
so I get a three-way call one day being
like hey can we shove a breathing tube
down your mom's throat and I'm just like
oh my God like they like I think it's
called like dialysis or something so
they did dialysis they did the breathing
tube and then
one of my mom's like workers at the shop
was like I haven't been able to see your
mom but I think you need to get down
here right now
and it's really sad because while I was
in communication with my mom all she was
texting me was I'm so worried about Dad
he just seemed so angry I'm so worried
about him as she's dying in the hospital
she's worried about my dad
and I'm like
it's it's even more sad because the last
thing she texted me was I love you
and that was the last thing I ever heard
from her
um
so I book a flight immediately
um and what's what's crazy is like I
remember I was at work one day
and I like told one of my co-workers I
was like I think my mom's dying
and I felt like wrong for saying that
because I'm like what if she's not like
what if everything is okay
but I like something was telling me like
this is it
so I booked the flight immediately home
and
I had to go from San Diego to Atlanta
from Atlanta to Chattanooga I get stuck
in Atlanta and my flight is delayed till
the next [__] morning
and I'm like are you kidding me like my
mom is literally dying so I have to Uber
two hours
and my phone is about to die so I'm
outside waiting for this Uber I've got
two percent on my phone and I'm thinking
if this Uber doesn't take me I have to
go all the way back into the airport
wait for my phone to charge come back
out here and get another Uber that'll
hopefully take me so I get in this Uber
and I'm like dude it's gonna be far and
he's like nope get out and I'm like
please like I've got one percent on my
phone I can't even get another Uber
without going all the way back into the
airport I'll pay you with cash like
please just drive and he's like
absolutely not
and I'm like my mom is dying like please
drive I my I called my dad when I'm in
the airport and he's so high that he
didn't even answer the phone so I'm
stuck in the Atlanta airport two hours
away from my dying mom and I can't get a
hold of my family I call some of my
family members and word for word I don't
know what to tell you
are you kidding me
so I'm like
I'm like so distraught because no one's
trying to help me this Uber's trying to
kick me out
and finally the Uber is like I'll do it
but you we have to cancel the ride
like on the app and I was like no so I
started to get out of the car and he's
like wait wait wait he's like take a
photo of my ID like I promise I'm not
gonna hurt you or anything like that
because he immediately knew I was like
pretty sketched out
and so I'm like fine but just drive and
he's sitting here yelling at me the
whole time I can't believe I have to
drive this far my wife is gonna kill me
and I'm like
just so annoyed but just needing to go
home desperately so he's like well I
have to get gas so he's like it's like
can you find a gas station so I'm on my
Google Maps finding a gas station he's
like oh I need you to find one that's
open because I need to pay with a credit
card or I need to pay with cash
and it's like one in the morning I'm
like oh my gosh can this guy be any more
difficult so like after like miles of
driving trying to find a gas station
open we find one and he's like I can't
find my money
he's like can you pay for it so I'm
immediately like this guy is trying to
do something so I start sharing my
location with people and I'm about to
get out and then
I'm like so over it and he could tell
and randomly he finds his credit card
randomly he was trying to get me to pay
for it the whole time
and so
the guy ends up being like kind of cool
after a while after I explained
everything
I get home
and I stayed with my mom's employee
um
and the next morning my dad calls and
he's like we gotta go to the hospital
and I think my dad like had sobered up a
little bit so he finally like knew that
I was in Tennessee like that night that
I got there
so technically it was still that day but
it was early mornings it's like 1am 2 am
my dad calls he's like we gotta go so me
and the employee go
and I just don't want to say her name of
course she she means a lot to me I just
don't want to say her name
we go to the hospital and
I watched my mom die right in front of
me
in the ICU and it was horrible like
seeing my mom like that
and I just remember like they're like
you just tell us when and we'll pull the
plug
and it's made me so sad that they were
just like pumping her full of air and
blood to stay alive
and so
my mom died
um January 25th 2022 from alcoholic
cirrhosis of the liver and kidney
failure
and I immediately knew that my dad was
not gonna be okay like as much as this
hurt me I was so worried about my dad
and
I remember
like maybe I stayed in Tennessee for
another two weeks so
um and we ended up doing like a memorial
thing at the tattoo shop and it was
beautiful and it was great it was great
like it was awesome I'm glad that we got
to have a really good memorial for my
mom
and tons of people were there
and uh one day like a week later or two
weeks later
me and my dad were driving
I was driving and he was in the
passenger seat because my dad still had
like the two DUIs he had a restricted
driver's license
I just lost it and I was like if you
don't get help me or you are next and
you know it and I was like I'm already
worried as hell about you but now I'm
kind of worried about me too not that I
was gonna hurt myself but
I just having to be in that like
survival mode for five years it makes
you think differently
so I was like Dad me and you were on the
chopping block next and if you don't get
help like I'm gonna lose my mind
and he ended up getting like so scared
that he is begging me to pull over
because he had never seen me so upset
and I was like just wasn't screaming but
I was like no seriously me and you are
next
sure enough
and my dad like had dreadlocks my dad
had like the most beautiful dreadlocks
that my mom had done on him and he's a
white guy both my parents are white
um
and like I don't know if it was that
I think it was the night the night
before the memorial for my mom so I
don't remember the exact date my dad
just shaved all this dreads off and I
knew then I was like he's not okay
the fact that he just buzz cut this hair
that took years to look like that
and um so I went I went to
um
I went back home to California and I
kept in contact with my dad every single
day because I was so worried about him
and
randomly I like went to work and I had
texted him about these potty pads for
the dogs and
um I was like hey what was the brand of
those potty pads and he didn't reply to
me and there's like a it's three hours
back in Tennessee East Coast time so I
was like well I'm not gonna text him
like when I got off work because it
would have been like super duper late
and so I was just like expecting him to
text me in the morning
and when I didn't see anything I already
knew I already knew that he was not okay
so I I blew up his phone and then I
contacted someone that I trusted to deal
with the situation that I knew he was
going to walk into
and then some other people I had reached
out and I said if this person doesn't
get there in time
or within the time frame I'm asking them
to get there can you do it so then a
bunch of people started to try and help
and I was like no no no because I I know
what you're gonna walk into
well
sadly like the person I texted he's so
freaking old he's in the hospital like
and he's like yeah I can come by later
so but he again only person that I would
have felt like could have dealt with
this
so he goes to the house and he calls me
he's like hey like where's the key blah
blah blah and tell him
and he's like okay well and he walks in
I'm on the phone with him still and he's
like I don't see anything I don't hear
anything I can hear the dogs barking and
he's like well I'm gonna look around I'm
gonna call you back
so I don't get a call for like 20
minutes I already knew I knew exactly
what happened my sister calls me
she's like yeah they found dad he hung
himself
and I just fell on the ground I guess
um the guy who I called he called my
sister to tell me just because he was
not sure how I was gonna react
uh so
they yeah my dad took his life and
um it's really sad because I didn't
realize like how easy it was for him
like we always had like camping
equipment
in our basement so he just looked left
turned right and did what he needed to
do
and
I just
is horrible
I went back home immediately
like a couple days later like I like got
my poor job like I texted him I'm like
yeah I gotta go back home again because
my other parent died
and
I literally got to see my dad
on a metal
cart in a body bag
as the last time I got to see my dad in
a body bag and I'm grateful that I was
even able to see him because I know a
lot of people that take their lives
depending on the way they do it they
can't see them luckily my dad didn't do
any
well okay he didn't do a lot of physical
harm he was I was able to view his body
and I kid you not we're at this funeral
home and all of a sudden people open up
the doors as we're viewing my dad and my
sister's like what the hell so and like
me my sister wasn't really like my
sister really wasn't around through it
all like I said we were as close as we
could be but
um so she just marches up there and
she's like why the hell are you opening
the doors closes them and then within
like five minutes they open again and
it's one of the workers of the funeral
home saying you have 10 more minutes
like are you kidding me I couldn't even
imagine like I I can't imagine like how
low you would have to be just tell a
family you have 10 more minutes to say
goodbye
to you know the final moments of being
able to view your loved ones so I mean
it was a joke and it was so sad
and
um my dad the toxicology report my they
found 46 milliliters of fentanyl found
in the blood which is like 46 000
milligrams
and like he only had like 10 milliliters
found in the blood when he totaled his
car
so it really made me realize because
there was no no nothing I mean there was
this was not premeditated my dad
probably walked downstairs
saw what he needed to hurt himself with
and was like here we go
and it's just so sad because there's
just absolutely no thought to it and
um it was weird because the the day that
I didn't get a reply from him
um they actually think that he passed
the day that he was found so when I was
texting him they think he was still
alive but he was just so out of it and
when you're on fentanyl like my dad
would like call me and not even know and
like butt dial me and leave me like 20
minute long voicemails of Just
Dance Like door slam you know all kinds
of [__]
so
yeah my parents passed away three weeks
apart
and then
a month later I had to put my dog down
my childhood dog that I like promised I
was gonna give her the best life I could
and like that's a whole nother thing
like even the dogs man like
you know my mom and dad's dog were there
when my dad ended his life now I have my
dad's dog after I re-homed him and found
out he wasn't being taken care of
so it's just sad like even this dog has
a whole story you know and he's never
gonna be able to talk to me but
oh my gosh it's just it's horrible and
now
I feel like
I came out here to California with this
huge plan of I'm gonna go to college I'm
gonna make my parents so proud and I'm
going to be so successful and then I
just had this feeling in the back being
like
it's not everything it seems and then
when all that happened I realized you
know what I have got to like chill and
not rush my life I'm seeing everyone my
age rushing and going to college and
getting their first apartment I'm here
like I have to start all the way over
um
how was all this changed you
um it's only been a year so much I think
it's really just obviously opened my
eyes to addiction and things like that
uh but it's it's made me like
foreign
at least like from from my point of view
realize like you don't really need to be
in a rush like because it makes me feel
guilty sometimes that I'm not in school
right now
um or that I'm not doing something else
but I'm like dude like when you have
something this big happen to you it
totally changes your perspective and I'm
I'm happy with living paycheck to
paycheck I'm happy going to work every
single day I know a lot of people would
be miserable but the fact that I don't
have to worry about me being able to
sleep at night making sure I have food
making sure my parents aren't going to
hurt themselves like that really changes
everything when you're constantly in
like a mode of having to survive and now
I'm like I have the whole day to decide
what I get to do I'm not gonna go to
school and do all this fancy [__] I'm
just not and even like I was gonna go to
esthetician school like Beauty School
um three days before my mom passed I did
the tour paid a good bit of my tuition
and I was like okay you know I dropped
out of a really nice school but I'm
finally gonna get my life together and
then boom my mom passes signed up for
the next month boom my dad passes I'm
done trying that you know I really need
to just enjoy being out here especially
coming all the way from Tennessee to
California it's way better out here as
far as just like the day-to-day so
I've just learned that
it's easy to compare yourself to other
people's past but when you have been
down a narrow path with tons of [__] in
the way it's okay to take it slow
and I've also realized one of the really
big things I've realized is that other
people can ruin your life and I always
say had my mom
never met the men she did in her life
she would probably be one of the most
successful women out there definitely
one of the like Kardashian Vibe because
she was just like such a hard worker so
independent she moved out here at 18.
just randomly packed up her stuff and
came out here for a guy who ended up
throwing her through a glass window and
destroyed all the nerves in her hands
stalked her tried to murder her and then
she was writing notes with my dad and
moved back for him and I'm like
just seeing the time span of her life
and all she did you know like
building a business having two homes
um she also went to vet tech school on
top of being a model a full-time body
piercer like being a mom having three
dogs like nothing was stopping her other
than her addiction and the people around
her and I've just realized like it makes
me never want like a boyfriend or like a
husband because I'm like you have no
idea like what someone else can do to
you and
it's really sad because it seemed like
my parents were like the perfect rock
and roll couple they went to all their
tattoo conventions and and I mean they
were hanging out with like so many rock
stars like there's photos of my mom with
like Zack Wilde and like those people
would stay at our houses like I even
like they would like be like hey can I
use your bathroom you know what I mean I
knew those people
and just it doesn't matter at the end of
the day like if if you have issues and
you put your issues with another person
it doesn't work
and it just it's scary people are
vulnerable and I think people can feed
on other people without meaning to I
don't I don't you know I know for a fact
my dad never meant to cause my mom any
harm and I know for a fact my mom never
meant to cause my dad any harm but
neither of them are alive today because
in my opinion of them being married
they had too much tied together and they
didn't know how to separate it and
including their addictions
October thank you so much for
sharing your story well thank you so
much for having me and let
him be here today
thank you very much thank you